[MUSIC PLAYING]
CHRISTIAN AWE: My
name is Christian Awe.
SHINGO FRANCIS: And
I am Shingo Francis.
CHRISTIAN AWE: And we have this
beautiful show at the Sezon
Museum, and we
brought some images.
It's great located, and the show
is called "Layers of Nature--
Beyond the Line".
It's at the Sezon
Museum of Modern Art,
and it really brings
people together.
I am an abstract painter.
Born and raised in
Berlin, Germany.
Just arrived this morning a
few hours ago straight here.
Gladly I made it
before the typhoon.
Here are a few
images of my work.
It's very colorful and
energetic and dynamic.
I paint in different layers.
And the beautiful
thing about the show
is that it brings
people together.
In this case, it's my
work in combination
with the work of Sam
Francis, Shingo's father.
And the beauty of it
is that one is painted
in 1958, the other one in 2017.
So there's a big resemblance.
And here you can see
one of Shingo's works.
Maybe you want to say
something about it.
SHINGO FRANCIS: OK, so
there's the three of us
here in this one picture,
Christian on the left.
On the right is my father.
It's Sam Francis.
Just a little brief
thing about him--
he's an abstract expressionist.
He was in Paris
in the '50s, kind
of part of what they called
the Informel School in Paris
with artists like Tapies.
And in Japan, I don't know if
some people know Hisao Domoto?
So he was part of that group.
And then at the same time
since he was American
and he had connections
in New York,
he was also friendly with
the abstract expressionists
in New York in the '50s.
And that's how he kind of got
his name as a, quote, unquote,
abstract expressionist.
So this is one of his
works in the '60s.
And then this
round thing you see
here is a large drawing that's
suspended from the ceiling.
And it's a type of drawing
where you could walk into it.
So it's an installation as
well, so you're enveloped
by this painting, drawing.
And there's a line,
as you can see,
at the middle of the
drawing, and that line
has reference to--
it could be like the horizon
and about perception,
about how things from a distance
look very thin and far away,
and then as you get closer
it starts to expand.
And then the circle
represents time.
So we're kind of in
this cyclical time frame
where we live 24 hours a
day, seven days a week,
30 days a month, and then
years, and then seasons.
So we're basically
kind of in this cycle.
That's how we live our lives.
So that's what that references.
CHRISTIAN AWE: And
it's quite huge.
It's 90 meters.
And the whole show is pretty
much based on works on paper
and about bringing, basically,
people together and having
kind of a show or face
off with one another.
And here's a beautiful
example of how you
reacted to your father's work.
SHINGO FRANCIS: Yeah, part
of the concept of the show
was also for Christian
and myself to do--
since my father's historical
and that's in their collection
and we're two living
semi young now--
we used to say young artist.
Now we saw we're
midcareer artists--
and so to have a response to
a painting in the collection.
So I chose this large painting.
Mine is on the left side and
my father's on the right side.
And the one on the
right is from 1978.
It's a period of his work
that's a great painting.
And for me as I
was growing up, I
watched him paint these
very large paintings.
And he had a very
large studio, and he
would paint these on the floor.
So it was just very interesting
for me to work with a painting
when I was growing
up and watching--
I don't know if I exactly saw
this particular painting be
painted, but he was doing
those kind of works.
And also he could really paint
in large scale and small scale.
And I think like
Christian too, he
could paint really
large and really small,
but it's not so easy to
do to go between scales.
And so I wanted to challenge
myself and do something
that was a large scale.
And also this space
really provided
for doing such a project.
CHRISTIAN AWE: Here you
can see some other work.
On the right side your
father's work from,
what is that, the '60s or '70s?
SHINGO FRANCIS: Oh no,
that's from the '80s.
So that's like '82, '83.
And so this is a very
overall painting of his,
and then this middle
red one is mine.
And I'll talk about
that series later.
CHRISTIAN AWE: So we were asked
to do something site specific,
and the first idea was that
I create a wall painting.
And the museum
asked me to do so.
I said, great, when can I come?
And they said, well, three
days prior to the opening.
I said, wow, I can't do that.
I need much more time.
They said, OK, then one week.
I said, I can't do that.
So I had to come
up with a concept,
and basically I painted on
[INAUDIBLE] on pieces of paper
that are like 10 meters long
and in total 12 meter wide,
like kind of an abstract
waterfall because the Sezon
Museum is based on the seasons,
the four seasons, and all
about nature.
So here you can see me working
at the museum installing it,
bringing it all there.
It's always a big challenge
to think of something
and go to a foreign
country and think,
is this going to work out?
How does it going to work out?
How can I actually do this?
This is how it turned out.
It was a pretty nice
process because the museum
is one of the most
important ones in Japan
and has this great collection
of artists like Rothko and--
SHINGO FRANCIS:
Pollock and Kandinsky.
CHRISTIAN AWE: --and everyone.
And so everything is
very well preserved,
and then comes this
young artist from Germany
and starts ripping stuff apart.
And they're like, oh my
god, what is he doing?
Is he destroying things?
So here you can see that
I actually really ripped
things and then took some
stones from the water
and put it underneath and
then made it in layers
as if it would actually be
like an abstract waterfall.
And the piece is called
"Seazon", like sea and zone.
And it's a resemblance
of that nature.
SHINGO FRANCIS: And
then nearby also there's
a waterfall called [INAUDIBLE].
It's a thousand
waterfalls or something.
And you got a picture
of that and seeing
that there was a
wonderful waterfall
right near the museum,
and it's the same water
that runs through
the museum grounds.
CHRISTIAN AWE: Yeah,
it's always about where's
inspiration coming from?
And here you can see
a little bit what
is actually in the collection.
A Calder on the right,
Rothko in the middle, and--
SHINGO FRANCIS: Jasper Jones.
CHRISTIAN AWE:
--Jasper Jones, yeah.
Great collection--
Pollock, Rothko.
Definitely worth to check out.
But my mission is
not only to paint.
It's also to act in space.
So this is a painting I made
in 2012 across from the Stasi
headquarters, so the former
secret service of East Germany.
And this painting is,
for me, about freedom.
Blue is the color
of freedom and hope.
And red in the
middle, yeah, energy.
And it's actually
also on that street
where, in 1945, the Russian
army drove into Berlin
and fought Nazi Germany.
And in that building still
a lot of the former workers
for the East German secret
service still work there,
and it was quite an
interesting project.
And so I started.
We had a lot of problem
of right-wing extremism
after the fall of the Berlin
Wall in that area, as I said.
I noticed that everyone who
got engaged in art and culture
opened up their mind and
became a better human being.
So I thought, well, how about
creating an outdoor museum
and painting pictures
in my district
and then all over the world
but actually also like
engaging the public in it?
So I did not only
paint these pictures.
First of all, the process
is quite interesting.
This one is 500 square meters.
So it was like as big as a
tennis court, 33 meters high.
And then you can
see with a sketch.
So I was painting it
right on that wall,
walking up and down 20 times
a day, 660 meters every day.
So over a period of 12
weeks I climbed four times
Mount Everest, which
in that process,
forget about going to the
fitness center and the gym.
Come and paint.
I lost nine kilos
painting that painting.
So here in that
black and white which
just looks like an
abstract painting,
if you look closely down
on that left bottom,
that's me actually standing
in the scaffolding.
Here you have that in color.
They get like an image about
size, what that actually means.
SHINGO FRANCIS: You
didn't use any projectors?
CHRISTIAN AWE: No, I
didn't use a projector.
First I though, how can
I actually draw this?
So I just made it freehand,
but you completely lose--
you have no idea where
in the painting you are,
what is happening 5,
10, 20 meters above you.
So I looked at art
history and checked
out how did Michelangelo
paint the Sistine Chapel?
And he was also there
painting it in Rome.
And the first draft he
made was also wrong,
and he had to demolish it.
And he used a technique
where he first painted in
on a piece of paper and
punched it with a nail
the certain spots like where's
the head, where's the elbow,
and then hold it up
against the ceiling
and use little pigments to
powder through these holes.
And when he took the
paper away, then a lot
of transformation
points were there.
So I did the same
process with a team,
and we had the fun of counting.
And it was 36,000
transformation points.
So I love doing
these big projects,
but what I love more is
engaging with the public.
And over the 12 weeks I
had an open studio outside
on the street, and I invited
the public every Friday
for four hours to come
and paint with me.
And I didn't know what
to expect back then,
but over the 12 weeks I had over
1,200 people joining workshops.
So there it was
clear for me, wow,
there is a real demand for
people that want to create,
that want to understand
what's going on.
So that was kind
of a start for me
to do this more professionally.
So then I started working
with different artists
from all over the world.
Here, a group from
Singapore, Social Creatives,
I invited painting
works together.
And then I went elsewhere.
Here did an artist in residence
in Princeton University
and had the surrounding
suburbs that are actually
pretty much run down.
Princeton is very well off.
The university is great.
But what is happening around
it is like Trenton, Newark, New
Jersey, kind of rough.
So I organized the bus
shuttle and invited
the kids who have never been
exposed to art and actually
education much and created
a program for them to come,
first, to paint on
shoes and T-shirts
that they got for free
so they all would come.
But then through that
you can teach them a lot.
First you sneak in a little
bit Keith Haring and Basquiat
and then taught them
some other stuff.
And that developed into
a very great project
where now this is still
ongoing and creating.
Then I extended this.
We have a big refugee crisis
in Europe, Africa, the Middle
East, and started to
bring people together
through art and culture.
I say, let's paint together.
There should be a
base of communication,
and what could be better than
cooking, doing sports, doing
music, or painting together?
So this is a group of young
refugees with German students
coming together.
Here's some other
projects I picked.
This is a series
of works in Germany
at a cultural center in Berlin.
That was new.
Actually nobody did come
because nobody knew.
The building kind of
looked like a little bit
like a shopping center.
And just after the paintings
were actually there,
people started coming.
And it's a very lovely
space also for music.
That is in Russia.
We created a project
in Perm, which
is the most Eastern European
city in the Ural Mountains.
And they're very well educated,
a lot of good-educated people.
But they had a problem that
especially the young woman
went away to Moscow, St.
Petersburg, or abroad.
And the government didn't
know what was happening.
So I had been engaged in a
lot of community projects,
and they brought me in
and they said, well,
you have to change something.
You have to bring
culture into the city.
It was an old weapon-industry
city, but culture was missing.
So I said, let's
create outdoor murals
of international artists,
of local artists,
and let's change
the whole situation.
And what happened was that
we created over 600 bus stops
and really changed the
outlook of the city.
And the background
you can see it's
kind of just cold and
not really inviting.
But then all of
a sudden the city
changed and was a big cultural
approach, and a lot of people
came in from all over.
The best opera in the
world at the moment you
can find in Perm.
Even "The New York
Times" wrote about it.
It's a big hub.
And now they have a
festival called The White
Knights of Perm, and
over a million people
participate every summer.
That's a project I
made in Miami where
we changed the whole
neighborhood, Wynwood,
that was really rundown,
really like a ghetto--
just drugs, prostitution,
homelessness.
Nobody at night
dared to go there.
Even in the day it
was hard to go there.
So with a collector friend
of mine, Tony Goldman,
we changed the neighborhood and
brought art into the streets.
And the concept was he was
owning a bunch of warehouses,
and we created the
biggest outdoor museum.
And right now there's,
I would say, probably
over 400 paintings outside
for people to go somewhere.
We created jobs.
And there was a park, and in
the park a lot of paintings.
And there's a
restaurant, actually
one of the best
restaurants that I created,
and Shepard Fairey made the bar.
So people could come and
actually go, and a lot of jobs
were created out of nowhere.
You have now this cultural
hub, and that really
changed the neighborhood
and created a lot of jobs.
Here you have a project
just from the start,
me painting a big piece.
Actually somebody was owning
a big building in Berlin
and he wanted to have
an outdoor mural.
But he wanted to
sell the building,
so he wanted to take the
piece along with him.
And this is a little
bit the process.
This is 12 by 30 meters.
So I paint in different layers.
That was over the
winter time, and then I
had to install it
at the building.
And this piece is
called [NON-ENGLISH]..
And [NON-ENGLISH] means,
in different West African
languages, a very warm welcome.
I painted it 2014-15, just at
the beginning of the refugee
crisis, and just
wanted to send out
the message that,
yeah, people are
welcome from the cultural side.
And I used this
to create prints.
And with these
prints I just started
to build a school in West
Africa in Burkina Faso.
And here's some images
from over there.
The problem they had was that
the next school was over seven
kilometers away, very hot.
You have been feeling it
lately how hot it can get,
but they are very often
around 40 and above.
So walking seven kilometers
is just often not an option,
especially as one of the
poorest countries in the world,
they have a high child-mortality
rate, around 10% still,
and a lot of young
women are not educated
because they have
to go to the fields,
help out with the family.
So I said, let's
change something.
And of the proceeds
of this painting,
I started with a group
of friends and my partner
to build a school.
And the whole community helped.
They were very anxious
to create something.
And we did this, and the school
started in the last year.
And it was planned
for 120 students,
was so successful that we
now have over 300 students.
And before they had about
a school rate of children
around 40% to 60%.
Now 98% go to the
school, and we are very
looking forward to also
get to that 2% to go there.
SHINGO FRANCIS: What was your
connection with Burkina Faso?
How did you get connected
to this community?
CHRISTIAN AWE: Well, let
me show you a little video.
I've always been doing
projects all over the world,
and my partner comes
from Burkina Faso.
And here are some
images of the city.
Then there's the school.
Very lovely to see that
wherever you go in the country,
just before school people
start doing their homework.
And we did the first
art lesson as well.
There was never any art at
school, which was lovely.
And we brought them 50 cameras.
No one of them has
a smartphone yet.
Nobody has a
picture of them yet.
So we got them disposable
camera that we develop for them.
Here you see what the
school looks like.
It's very lovely to see
how people have the urge
also there to create and
to be educated and really
want this to happen and
to give them a chance.
And it's so lovely to see
that through art and education
you can do something like this.
Eri, as a little thank
you for the talk today,
I actually brought you
one of these drawings
that the students made.
[APPLAUSE]
The initial plan was actually
not only to build a school.
We wanted to build a hospital.
But I said I don't know.
What does medicine
mean in Africa?
How can I, as an artist from
Berlin, do a project like that?
Then I said, OK, a
school, I have been there.
I know how that goes.
And so I said OK.
Now the school was
built successful.
Now I'm actually thinking
of creating this hospital.
And we started, we
built the first part.
And this happens to
project like this.
This is another painting I made
right next to the Holocaust
monument in Berlin.
In the background you see
the Sony Center in Berlin.
Actually on the right
there you have the image
which is supposed to be the
Mount Fuji of the Sony Center.
And there you can
see me painting
looking like Spider-Man.
And the piece
itself also consists
of blue, blue, the color of
the water of the Mediterranean,
of freedom.
From the left comes like a kind
of a red-orange rising Phoenix.
From the right side green, the
color of hope, and they meet.
There happens an encounter.
And these white
splashes are actually
the abstract escape
routes from Africa
and the Middle East into Europe.
And with that I also
made a printing edition.
That printed edition goes 100%
in building that hospital.
Here, more projects I'm just
working on with Porsche.
This is a draft which
I want to create right
after I come back from Japan.
It's a new big Porsche
center in Hamburg.
And there I'm going to
paint that on stickers
and actually then want to create
my first sculptures out of it.
And all of this also
for the proceeds
of continuing giving back.
I think this is very important
to use the knowledge,
and that is what
I want to send out
is a message to give
back to community,
inspire others, inspire you.
I think Google is a
very great company.
It has achieved
a lot, but I also
do feel that there is a big
creative crisis in the Silicon
Valley.
I think there is a lot of
good stuff been created,
but what has actually been done
to end hunger, to end poverty,
to end the water crisis?
I think there can be
done so much more,
and I hope you will contribute
to make the world a better
place.
[APPLAUSE]
SHINGO FRANCIS: My presentation
is more just about my work
and about where I
draw my work from.
This is a painting
that I've been doing,
and it's a painting
that reflects.
And what I've been
interested in lately is,
well, in looking
at art and looking
at images, a lot of times we're
really looking at our screens.
And whether it's through
websites on our computers
or looking at
Instagram, Facebook,
what have you on our
mobile phones and iPads
and what have you, at least in
the art world, a lot of times,
and also people I
know, we're looking
at images now distributed
through the screens
and through digital
media and everything.
And I find myself
and I find others
talking about how we
look at art and that
through looking at
art through the screen
that we feel like
we saw the art.
Like, oh, I saw this painting
or I saw this sculpture.
And in a sense it's
replacing our experience
with actually seeing
the real object
because artworks are objects
that exist in space and time.
And so I thought
about like, well,
what would be a painting
that is either really
difficult to photograph
or perhaps impossible
to photograph?
And of course you could
photograph anything,
but I wanted to make
a painting that was
really elusive in that sense.
And so this painting
is painted purely
with a type of paint that comes
from mimicking a beetle's skin.
And in Japan it's
the type of beetle
that they've been using to
make [JAPANESE] for kimonos
for a long time.
So from one direction
it's one color,
and from another direction it
turns into a different color.
So it's what they
call dichromatic.
So they have these
dichromatic paints now,
and I've been using them
for my own paintings.
But since I started
thinking about how can I
make an object that's really
elusive to photograph,
I just started purely painting
with this pigment, this paint.
And so this painting
on the top part here,
it's kind of washed out, but
it's blue and it's green.
So that's one color
when it's reflective.
It's the primary color, what
I call the primary color.
When it's reflecting
it's blue and green,
and then when it's
not reflecting
it's the contrast in
color which is yellow
and like violet or magenta
or pink or what have you.
So it's the opposite color.
So basically these
colors just change
depending on how the light
is reflected off the painting
and how the light
sits on the painting.
So you really
can't experience it
just by taking a picture of
it because the picture is only
going to reflect the way
the light was at that time.
CHRISTIAN AWE: I think
it's quite beautiful
that in this day and age
so many things are just--
you can reproduce them, but a
lot of values are disappearing.
Everything is mass produced.
But I think art you
have to see in person,
and it gives you something--
it gives you an experience, and
your paintings of this series
is definitely something that
has a certain aura you can just
experience being there.
And I think that is why art
will always stay valid and get
even more and more important.
SHINGO FRANCIS:
Yeah, and I think
it's this thing about
virtual and real.
Well, this kind
of painting forces
you to see the object
in person, basically.
So yeah, our experiences are
getting very much tangled up
in-- and I kind of
brought this one first
because this is a tech
company and a lot of things
happen online.
That is the platform.
Yet at the same
time it's, I think,
kind of negotiating
and navigating
what we experience in
space and time as opposed
to what we experience
online or what have you.
And I think this is we're
in the new kind of era
of whether-- even with
commerce and what have you.
So just my background, I
grew up both here in Japan
and also in the United States.
And as a young child,
since my parents
were separated when
I was really young,
I spent my life in both places.
And kind of like my segue
into art was really poetry.
And specifically this
is William Blake,
and he's an 18th-century
poet in England.
And he combines
words and imagery.
So he always has these
drawings that accompany--
or they can be illustrations
that accompany his poems.
And so I was as a young, I
don't know, teenager or so,
I related to
reading these poems,
and I could understand
what it's saying
in relation to my own life.
And that gave me the impetus
to say, oh, I can do this,
or I can relate to this and
I want to tell my own story.
So I started by writing poetry.
And I was painting,
but it really
wasn't something that I--
it was more something since
my father was a painter,
I got to get lessons
as a young child.
And so that came in from
a different direction,
but really where I really
kind of attached myself to
at the beginning was poetry.
And this is another example of
William Blake's illustrations
or drawings where this is
the souls getting sucked up
from hell, I think, and they're
going to purgatory or something
like that.
So he's kind of
biblical, but I thought
they were really interesting.
And I spent time in
Florence to learn
how to paint in the more
traditional, classical way,
and spent time there copying
various old master paintings.
And then when I was in
Florence at the time--
this is Joan Mitchell.
So I was able to meet with--
she was an abstract
expressionist painter as well,
and she had a big
influence on me,
something like what
Christian says about life.
And I bring her up because she
was really emphatic in saying
paint what you feel.
Paint what it is that's inside
of you and bring it to life.
And her paintings
are very expressive.
They are emotional, I
think, very emotional.
But I think it's a way to
express your emotional life.
And I think there's also a real
freedom in painting this way
and making your own marks
and your own gestures.
This is my kind of
early work where
I was painting these kind of
very semi gestural paintings.
And then eventually I
started to kind of morph
into different things, and I
got interested in coming back
to Japan and Zen Buddhism.
And that is something
I got interested in,
like what is Japanese culture?
What is kind of the soul
of Japan to say in a way?
And Zen being something that
ultimately came from China,
but in Japan it
kind of very much
became a kind of
refined form of Buddhism
that has a lot to
do about space.
So I spent time at a
Buddhist monastery,
and really it forced
me to kind of look
into spending time
with your own self
and sitting with your
emotions, your thoughts,
and learning how to create
your own space within.
That's pretty abstract.
That's kind of an
abstract way of--
it's hard to explain
in that sense.
But I felt that, as far
as Japanese culture,
that it's a big part
of Japanese culture
is to understand
how space is used.
And I think that's
really reflected
for now in contemporary
architecture and design
as well.
And someone who kind of crossed
between the two cultures
that I was really influenced
by as well was Isamu Noguchi?
Anybody know of Isamu Noguchi?
So he was someone that spent a
lot of time in both cultures,
in the US and Japan, and learned
a very unique style of working
with a Japanese tradition
and the European tradition.
And this is his
place in Shikoku.
It's right outside of Takamatsu.
And he had a working studio.
And so if you ever get
a chance to go there,
I would recommend
going to this Noguchi
Foundation in Takamatsu.
And it's just his
way, his sensibility
of bringing the Eastern and
Western aesthetics together.
And then this is a
really interesting book,
"In Praise of
Shadows", by Tanizaki,
his philosophy about
space, light, shadow,
and just kind of the simplicity
and the way light and shadow
evokes emotions
and sets the scene.
So I'm just kind of running
through these things
since we don't
have too much time.
And then on the other
hand this is James Turrell
and one of his sky windows.
So growing up also
in California,
I was very attracted to the
space and light movement.
And it's funny, he came to
Japan and got very influenced
by Japan and brought
that back to California,
and then he
influenced California.
So there's this kind
of real dialogue
going between Japan and the
West Coast of the United States.
And this book, "The Art
of Light and Space",
really explains the
whole philosophy
behind the
light-and-space artists.
And this is Robert Irwin.
So it's this idea of
just taking perception
and how our perception
is altered really
affects the way we see
things and experience things.
And this is an
artist Larry Bell.
He made these glass
cubes, and they
have a certain coating on it.
And this also, it's
really another object
you have to see in person where
it really changes depending
on how you're looking at it.
This is an early work of mine.
So again, looking at
how perception works,
there's a very faint
line at the bottom,
and I think it's really hard
to see it with this screen.
Right here there's like
a very, very vague,
really hard-to-perceive line.
One thing I think
is being confronted
with basically a
nonrepresentational image
of flatness or it
could be space,
but you're confronted
with, in essence, nothing.
And it's also in reference to
for a long time paintings been
about making illusionistic space
like landscapes or the figure
or what have you, and
then modernism really
flattened out the plane,
meaning it brought everything
to the front.
So this has reference
to that, kind
of really either flattening
out space or, in Japan,
looking at [JAPANESE]
or [JAPANESE],, the void,
and confronting the void.
And that's kind of
a theme I've been
very interested in with
my work, and I'm just
really interested in
what people experience
when they're confronted with
very little, essentially.
So this is a show of what the
works look like an exhibition
setting.
CHRISTIAN AWE:
Which was also very
nice to see at Sezon Museum
because we're actually
quite contrary.
You're like calm in
some of your works
about emptiness,
nothingness, very reduced,
and I'm more about energy.
And your father actually kind
of hold us together and--
SHINGO FRANCIS: Well yeah,
that's the interesting part.
CHRISTIAN AWE: --built
a beautiful bridge.
SHINGO FRANCIS: Yeah.
My father uses a lot
of white in his work,
but then there's a lot
of gestures and action
going on between the lines.
Whereas Christian is
very alive and colorful
and a lot going on.
So slowly these works
have certain compositions
that come into them, but
essentially most of the work
is you're looking at this very
either flat or deep space,
depending on how you look at it.
And these are some
prints I've been doing.
And this is as you go along.
And then there's some color
that starts to come in.
So more recently
I've been doing ones
where you're still getting
a majority of a very
flat and static space with
some gestures happening
at the top and the bottom.
So that's really one of
my very interesting places
where I'm really interested
in is what people experience.
What is it when you're
confronted with basically
nothing, but is it nothing?
Is there something
to project onto it?
How are you going
to respond to it?
What is your response?
And that is an inflation
shot of the works.
And then there's
the body of work
that has to do with this
band, like you saw earlier.
So this is one of the
large installations
like the one at Sezon.
They could be enveloped.
So these bands starting to be
about the band in the center
being a certain space,
and then on the outside
is another space.
So for me it was more about
the internal and the external,
so the inside being broken into
another space that has more
to do with, on a
psychological level,
on the internal life
of an individual,
like what it is
that you're thinking
and what you're feeling,
and then our environment.
What is happening
outside of ourselves?
What is going on in
our surroundings?
What events are happening-- so
things that may be happening
to us and how they affect us.
And of course there's a
clear line between the two,
yet at the same time
I think they very much
affect each other.
There's an affect that
happens between what
it is that we're
thinking and feeling
that gets projected outward and
then also things that happen
outside of our lives around
us and our environment
that affect our internal lives.
So it's this play between the
internal and the external.
I'll just keep it at that.
[APPLAUSE]
CHRISTIAN AWE: Are there
any comments or questions?
AUDIENCE: Question?
CHRISTIAN AWE: Yes?
AUDIENCE: How do you know
your artwork is complete
and stop painting?
I am from engineering,
and as an engineer
there is a concept
of overengineering.
And we have priorities
and deadlines.
All those force
me to stop working
on some file or software,
to [INAUDIBLE] I mean.
This is good enough, so
move on to the next one.
How do artists
decide when to stop?
CHRISTIAN AWE:
It's very difficult
for different artists.
Friends of mine
used to say whenever
the transporter is coming,
the artwork is finished.
For me personally,
it is a feeling.
I know exactly.
There are two approaches.
One is that I completely just
create and experiment and just
go with the flow,
and then I know
how much I have to do until
something is finished.
It just feels right.
And when a painting is finished
for me, it is finished.
But there are other artists
that always go back and say,
I have to do something.
There's a German
painter that is not
allowed to visit
a lot of museums
because his works are
in it and he can't stop.
He goes to the works that
already belong to the museum
and has his brushes there.
SHINGO FRANCIS: Oh no.
Oh my God.
CHRISTIAN AWE: He
goes there and says,
oh man, I have to
correct a little bit here
and a little bit there.
It's very hard sometimes.
SHINGO FRANCIS: Well, I've
learned to stop before--
it's easy for me to overpaint
something, to overly do it.
And with painting it's kind
of hard because once you go,
you can't really
take it off, right?
And you can maybe go over
it with white or whatever
and try to--
CHRISTIAN AWE: It would
be great to have like
a Photoshop go back button.
SHINGO FRANCIS: Yeah, you could
go back in time or something.
So I've learned over the
years that although maybe I
should keep going,
but I say, well,
I'll wait and wait until
tomorrow and look at it again.
So it's kind of like
refreshing yourself
because it's easy to overdo it.
That's my experience.
It's easy to say, oh man, I
liked it when it wasn't so--
because my work,
as you could see,
it's kind of like a
less-is-more kind of thing.
And then you have a sense.
It's like, OK.
Same with Christian.
It's more of a kind of a feeling
that if I do too much of it,
it's going to just
lose what it has now.
CHRISTIAN AWE: There
was another question?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
Thank you.
I have a question
for both of you guys.
So the first one will
be for Shingo-san.
And I'd love to
ask about, so when
you talked about
the Sezon Museum,
you say you painted after
your father's painting.
And I wanted to ask if you
think about your identity
and that's a reason why you
do it or why did you do that?
And then also for
Awe-san, I would
like to ask about
when you started
doing community art,
[INAUDIBLE] specific art,
did you always count
the idea of doing
that since before or all of
a sudden you kind of decided?
You were like, oh,
I want to do that?
That's [INAUDIBLE].
SHINGO FRANCIS: So
for the painting
I did in response
to my father, that
was a concept that
came from the museum.
They asked us to choose a
painting from the collection.
And as being a son of-- when
you're in the same line of work
as one of your parents,
it's like you go through--
and so in my 20s I really
went through this whole thing
like, oh God, I have to deal--
people always comparing
you and this and that.
It used to bother me a lot.
I thought about
changing my last name.
I went through this mini crisis,
like oh my God, am I ever
going to--
it's this whole
Oedipus kind of thing.
Do I have to kill my
father or something?
Do I have to become more
famous than him or something?
You go through this whole thing.
And so I've had an
experience where
I've kind of gone beyond
that and found how I work
and what kind of
approach I have.
So when I got that
recommendation it was like,
oh yeah, I know
what I want to do.
So it was pretty natural,
whereas 15 years ago I
think I would have
had a total identity
crisis, like oh my God.
It would have been either
a competition in my mind
or I would have probably
refused, would have been
one or the other.
So it was a good
experience this time.
CHRISTIAN AWE: For your question
about community project,
committee art, for
me being raised
in East Germany in a
socialistic system,
it was always very normal for
me to engage to do something
with others, for others.
It was never really
only for my own pleasure
or for my own gain or wealth.
So it was very normal, and
I feel especially whoever
can should give something back.
And as an artist, we have
a voice, so why not use it?
And just treat people as
you want to be treated.
Do something.
Stand for something.
And I feel it's very
interesting also
how I feel that, for
example, Japan is opening up.
Also with the
Olympics coming 2020,
how you portrayed
yourself at the soccer
championship cleaning up
the stadium afterwards,
leaving nice notes.
This is something,
leading by example--
such a high-technology world
over here but then still
so Zen Buddhism and all
about nature and giving back.
And in a way, I think
leading by example
and inspiring others
is what we have to do.
And I actually really
liked how you said Awe-san.
It was the first
time I heard that.
SHINGO FRANCIS: Awe-san.
We have to call you that now.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
And thank you so
much for sharing.
It was truly, truly inspiring.
And my question is,
especially in Japan,
we see different
forms and frameworks
of presenting and
sharing art emerging.
For example, now there
is an ongoing digital art
exhibition by teamLab,
or you go to Naoshima
and you experience art
pieces, installations
amidst the nature that let
them shine in a new light.
So I was wondering
in your perception,
what is the next
phase in of actually
sharing the art with others?
What's coming?
CHRISTIAN AWE: I think it's
very important to break down
the barriers of art.
A lot of people would never
go to a museum or a gallery
or ask about buying
something if they feel
forced to engage in something.
I think it should be
much more normal to be
taught at in school.
That doesn't happen
everywhere in the world.
It's all about mathematics,
physics, and so on,
but I actually feel
that these soft values,
you can learn best in writing
poems, engaging in sport,
in music.
What can we do in the
digitalized worlds
where very soon machines can
do much more things better
at a much faster space?
What is the value of us humans?
That is what we
have to filter out
and that is what
we have to learn
and being taught in school.
And that is really the priority.
SHINGO FRANCIS: What can I add?
Well, these different platforms
like teamLab doing their thing,
I mean, I think it's great
to have various ways to reach
people, various mediums to
reach people to experience art.
And teamLab making their
work that's catered
to that platform.
And there's a lot
of art now being
generated through digital
mediums and what have you.
And I mean film when it first
came into being, moving images
with a completely new art form.
And I think there's
always going to be
new art forms being created,
and it's how you experience it.
But I think it's important.
There's barriers, this idea
about like art being exclusive
or art being for, oh, I have
to have an understanding of it,
that these notions kind
of get broken down.
And the definition of art
gets kind of tricky too.
Well, what is art
and what is not art?
But having the ability to
have access for museums--
well, the institutions
really need to step up,
and some have-- step
up and make it more
inviting so people
can understand
what it is that they're looking
at, what they're experiencing.
So text is important
in that part.
And in education, it's
true, art gets cut.
It's the first funding that gets
cut, and usually in education.
CHRISTIAN AWE: Since we are
running out of time now,
let me maybe end up with this.
I believe that art is one of
the most important profession
in a society, whether
it's free or dictatorian.
I feel like that every
big company and even
the politicians should have art
advisors and philosophers being
to re-evaluate what the culture
is-- where are we heading--
because artists are
among the most free,
and we are not
really like bound.
We don't have to
think a certain way.
We are free thinkers and
therefore leading a way
into the future.
And that's why I
can just encourage
companies and politicians to
have advisors in that way,
into a better future.
SHINGO FRANCIS: Well,
and the Greeks, right?
Poets and philosophers
were advising the council.
Well, thank you Eri.
[APPLAUSE]